DAVID WHITE: Hi,
welcome to Google.
My name is David White.
I'm going to talk to you today
about running your Windows
workloads on Google Cloud.
I'm a Solution Manager here at
Google in the infrastructure
modernization group
and before joining
Google I've spent most of my
career as a COO, CIO, VP of IT.
Essentially I've spent more
of my time as the customer
than on this side of the table.
So I want to talk to you a
little bit today about why
customers are running their
Microsoft workloads on GCP,
talk a little bit about
Microsoft licensing options
in GCP, and then we'll talk
about phase transformation
of your Microsoft workloads in
your Microsoft applications.
So the first question that we
often hear is, why on earth
would anybody bring Microsoft
workloads to Google Cloud?
And I think this more than
anything else answers it best.
Urs Holzle, our
senior vice president
of engineering and
technical infrastructure,
"We're committed to
making GCP a first class
platform for running
Microsoft workloads."
And if you look back
over the last five years
since he made that
statement, Google
has continued to invest in
optimizing and modernizing
and bringing in the
technologies and tools that
allow you to bring your
enterprise Microsoft
workloads into Google Cloud.
Today, thousands
of our customers
are running Windows
workloads in Google Cloud,
amounting to billions of core
hours every year of Windows
workloads.
Some of our recent customers,
including Travix and Volusion
and, most recently,
TELUS International,
talk about how they have
brought their Windows
workloads into Google and what
a great decision it's been.
So why do people want to
bring Microsoft workloads
into Google?
First and foremost, Google
has phenomenal infrastructure.
Between our underlying
compute capabilities,
the speed of our storage, the
robustness of our network,
and the security that
we bake into everything,
Google always wants to make
sure that we provide the best
for our customers that we can.
Google also preferences
giving customers choice.
We want to be able to
provide an array of offerings
so that customers
can choose which
different pieces are going
to fit their solutions best.
And Google, first and foremost,
is committed to modernization
and to an open platform.
We are devoted to the
open source community,
and we are the innovators
behind things like Kubernetes,
TensorFlow, GKE, and other tools
that are commonly used today
throughout a variety of clouds.
So let's talk a little bit
about our three staged approach.
First, is to migrate.
So we help you with
a lift and shift,
moving from your
on-premises data center
into Google Cloud, migrating
your VMs into our Google
Compute Engine, and
potentially even
upgrading those versions
of the operating system
where possible.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a moment.
This is using our Migrate
for Compute Engine tool.
By doing this, we work with
you to get the right balance
of your bring your own
licensing capabilities versus
a pay-as-you-go licensing.
We help you take advantage
of Google technology,
such as CPU overcommit
and custom VM shapes,
and we allow you to leverage
suspending and resuming
your VMs, so that you
can save on costs when
things aren't actually needed.
Next, we'll talk a little
bit about our modernization
opportunities.
These are the ways
in which we can
help you bring your Windows
applications into containers
and still be in Windows.
Or taking advantage of our
fully managed service offerings,
like Cloud SQL or
Managed Active Directory.
And all of this results in a
greater efficiency, tighter bin
packing, and better
cost optimization.
Lastly, we can talk
about how we can help you
transform your applications.
Moving to more open standards,
like Postgres or MySQL,
or moving your .NET on
Windows into .NET core.
Or lastly taking your .NET
applications and containerizing
them for ease of management
and ease of scale.
Where do I go?
As I said, Google
wants to provide you
a variety of choices
so that you can choose
per workload what the best
destination is for your Windows
applications.
First choice is the
Google Compute Engine.
This is our standard
Google VM environment
where we can help you bring
your on-prem VMs using
our Migrate for Compute Engine.
If there are applications
that it makes more sense
to stay in VMware,
we can help you
stay in VMware with our
VMware as a service offering.
It allows you to leverage
native VMware tools like HCX
to do your migrations
and helps you
move those workloads
from VMware on premises
into VMware and Google
Cloud, where you can still
take advantage of all of
the Google Cloud features
and services.
Lastly, for those items that
are appropriate to containerize,
we can help you with our
Migrate for Anthos tool to take
your .NET applications that
are running in VMs today
and actually put them into
Windows containers running
in Kubernetes.
Similarly, for
Microsoft SQL, you
have the opportunity to continue
running your own Microsoft
SQL on Windows in our
Google Compute Engine
in a virtual machine.
Or we can help you
migrate to SQL for Linux,
thus eliminating the need to
pay for the underlying operating
system of Windows
because Linux is free.
Or, if you want to get out
of the business of managing
your own SQL server,
we can help you
move to cloud SQL, where we
were the fully managed service
offering, and you
just need to tap in.
So a little bit of an
overview on licensing
with a quick disclaimer.
This is guidance at best.
Please make sure that
you check the details
of your individual
Microsoft licensing.
So essentially,
there are two models
for how you can take care
of your Microsoft licenses
within Google Cloud.
The first is very easy
and straightforward.
It's just pay as you go.
If you'd like to deploy
a Microsoft Windows
Server in Google Cloud, when
you're creating that VM,
you select the
Windows Server image.
And that image will not
only have the Windows Server
operating system, it will also
have the necessary licensure.
And that gets billed
on per second basis.
You spin it up,
the billing starts.
You spin it down,
the billing stops.
Similarly, for SQL
server, if you'd
like to select one
of our Windows images
that has SQL server
already installed,
we can charge you per
minute for the time
that that SQL server is up.
And then when that SQL server
is down, the billing stops.
This is particularly useful
for test or dev or staging
environments that
don't need to run 24/7
that you want to be able
to bring up and bring down.
Similarly, for other Microsoft
applications like SharePoint
or Exchange, we leverage our
third party partners that are
able to provide images and
pay-as-you-go licensing
and cost.
For our BYO licenses, we offer
our sole tenant nodes, which
we'll discuss in a moment.
Your eligibility to
bring your own license
will still depend on
your Microsoft licensure.
But where you are entitled
to bring your licenses,
our sole tenant nodes
allow you the place
to do that with
dedicated hardware.
SQL server by the terms of
your software assurance.
You have the ability to bring
your SQL server licenses
wherever you'd like, as well
as SharePoint and exchange
in other Microsoft applications.
This is the use case
for 24x7 applications,
where you need to keep
them running all the time.
So some people have
discussed October 2019 when
it comes to Microsoft licenses.
There was a change,
based on October 2019,
for licenses purchased after
that versus licenses purchased
before that.
For Windows Server
licenses purchased
before October of 2019,
as long as these licenses
were purchased prior to that--
or associated with
larger agreements that
were created prior to that--
you should be able to bring
those windows licenses
to GCP within the guardrails--
within the boundaries--
of your Microsoft license.
For SQL server, as long as
you have software assurance,
you're able to continue to bring
those licenses over to Google.
In order to make sure that
we have all of our Is dotted
and Ts crossed, we've engaged
the services of a third party
company called SoftwareOne.
SoftwareOne is a premier partner
of both Google and Microsoft
and has provided us
prescriptive guidance
on the details of
Microsoft licensure.
And as you can see in both
cases, Windows Server and SQL
server, there is
likely a path to be
able to bring those
licenses over.
One of the requirements
for being in compliance
with Microsoft
licensing is the ability
to generate a report
of the operating
system and the servers
that they're running on.
Google takes that
complexity away
by providing these
reports for you on demand.
As I mentioned,
sole-tenant nodes.
Sole-tenant nodes
mean that you have
sole control over the
underlying hardware
for the virtual machines
that you're deploying.
You can mix and match
Linux and Windows VMs
on those sole-tenant nodes.
But, in addition,
you can flip a switch
that allows you to
trigger a CPU overcommit.
Essentially, what
that means is you
make it appear as though
there's twice as many CPUs
available on that host.
And for those applications
that are not overly resource
intensive, it allows you
to pack twice as many VMs
onto that same hardware.
So you can get much
more cost-effective use
of that underlying hardware
that you're now using.
Custom VMs are an outstanding
tool for SQL server.
So SQL server is
licensed by CPU,
but is very, very RAM hungry.
For many Cloud providers,
what that means is, in order
to get the additional
memory that SQL wants,
you have to increase
your VCPU count.
Meaning you're not only being
charged for the CPU cores,
but you're also having to pay
licensure for SQL and Windows
for those additional use
that you really don't need.
With custom VMs
and GCP, we allow
you to scale that RAM and CPU
core separately so that you
can create that
custom shape that's
going to give you the optimal
amount of RAM for your SQL
Server or other
applications while still not
having to overpay for CPUs
that you don't actually need.
Windows Server 2008
is another topic
that we frequently hear
from our customers.
Windows Server 2008
R2 has gone end
of life, which
means that Microsoft
will no longer provide security
updates or patches for it
without having to purchase
potentially expensive
extended security updates.
Migrate for Compute
Engine allows
you to take those 2008 R2
servers from your data center
and, in the process
of migration,
actually upgrade them in flight,
so that when they land in GCE,
they land as 2012 servers, which
is a fully supported operating
system.
That is provided at no
cost to our customers.
By using the different
tools and technology
that Google provides, optimizing
your per second billing,
being able to shape
the custom VMs,
taking advantage of preemptible
VMs, so for those workloads
that just need episodic
access to compute,
you can spin them up
and spin them down
at a greatly reduced price.
We also have an ongoing
recommendation system
where you can see
at a VM by VM level
what the recommendations are
for scaling up or scaling down
based on your actual
utilization of those VMs,
allowing you to right-size
your spend and right-size
your utilization of resources.
Let's talk a little bit
now about modernizing.
So some of the ways that we
help you modernize around SQL.
By moving to SQL on
Linux, for example,
you remove the underlying
need to license the Windows
operating system.
By moving to Managed
SQL, you don't
have to pay the SQL
license costs at all
because all of that is managed
within our cloud SQL offering.
And by moving that
responsibility of management,
we may even be able to help
you move from enterprise
to standard to web.
And, as you can see, moving
from server enterprise to SQL
server standard can be a
tremendous cost savings.
Being able to move all
the way to SQL server web
can be a phenomenal
cost savings.
Windows Server
containers in GKE.
This is our ability to
support Windows containers--
that can either be
spun up from scratch
or can come over as a result of
our Migrate for Anthos tool--
that can pick up your
VMs from your data center
and deliver them as
containers in Kubernetes.
One of the best advantages
of containerizing
these applications
is license cost.
With your Microsoft licenses,
once the underlying VM host
has been licensed for
the operating system,
you can deploy as
many containers
on top of that operating system
as the hardware will support.
So, again, this provides
much better bin packing,
much greater efficiency,
much more cost
effective use of the resources
you're already paying for.
Our managed service offering
for Active Directory
allows you to get out from
under the burden of having
to manage your Active
Directory infrastructure
and still be able to use it as
the security and profiling tool
that you want to be
able to use it for.
Typically, what we see when
we sit down and we work with
customers on optimizing their
costs once they've moved
their Microsoft workloads
into GCP is we can see as much
as a 50% cost savings by
blending your BYO licenses
and your pay-as-you-go licenses,
by being able to take advantage
of the CPU overcommit, and
using some of the other tools
and technology that
Google provides,
which allows you to then take
that savings and reinvest it
in your transformation.
This is where you
really want to end up
when all is said and done.
This is moving
into Cloud Native.
This is moving into open source.
This is what gives you the
scalability and the flexibility
that really underpin your
digital transformation.
So being able to move from SQL
Server to PostGres or MySQL,
or helping you migrate your .NET
for Windows applications onto
.NET Core that runs on Linux,
or even just containerizing
your .NET applications, so you
can start making incremental
steps towards containerization.
Using our Google Kubernetes
engine or, possibly,
even going into Anthos.
Ultimately, we want to be
able to partner with you.
To look at your Microsoft
workloads and help you identify
which applications
should be retired,
which ones can be
migrated into GCP,
such as third party
ISV applications,
which internally created
applications are easy rewrites,
such as moving from
.NET to .NET Core,
or which ones are going to be
more complicated or that may
yield better results by moving
into things like serverless,
through App Engine and Cloud
Run, and then, ultimately,
what are the applications
that you're just going to have
to maintain until their
functionality is completely
replaced with
other applications.
So, in summary, we
want to help you
start at the left with
your Microsoft workloads
and your Microsoft
servers running
in your on-premises location,
lift and shift and migrate them
into Google Cloud using
our tools and technologies,
working with you to optimize and
get the right balance of spend
for your compute and
for your licensure,
and then, ultimately,
help you through
your digital transformation into
Cloud Native and open source.
Thank you, and we look
forward to working with you
in the future.